hello everybody my name is markiplier
and if you know me then you know that I
like my horror games like I like my
coffee and I like my coffee half as much
as I like my women so if I like this
game 3/4 as much as I like my women and
my coffee combined then I'm definitely
gonna love this game but this game gets
me it knows that I don't like sewers and
it knows and I don't like jump scares so
it's gonna throw nothing but jump scares
and sewers at me as I walk sorry ed had
to laugh oh my god this is awful hi okay
I um I I need to explain myself I saw
this game and I was gonna pass it over
but then I thought to myself could it
really be that bad I mean really could
it really be that bad and yet here we
are walking down a sewers waiting oh man
it's nothing like having a game with no
gameplay at all none no gameplay at all
it removes all the unnecessary elements
and just keeps you walking down this one
linear path with no branching choices no
story at all nothing at all besides
walking and waiting for the next jump
scare - was that the SCP noise that that
is suspense right there that is what it
really means to be Game of the Year and
I believe I firmly believe that this is
a next contender for the greatest game
ever made I do not think I have ever had
this much of an emotional experience
bobbing up and down with my arm and my
birdcage or whatever the hell this is
bobbing straight up in town as I
continue forward
lilium bouncing on the unknown grunt oh
no I'm getting a chill down my spine
it's dirt uh-oh there's nothing okay
well I I really love the amount of work
that they put into this well hi oh
no hun oh no oh oh I thought it was
gonna oh I thought oh well oh the
misleading the misdirection I thought he
was gonna look behind him but no he got
out completely fine and lived long happy
life oh god I've never experienced such
an emotional rollercoaster this truly is
the greatest game I have ever played
game of the year ten out of ten
you